this is a robot valet a magnificent
machine that wants to save humanity from
the mundane 'ti of parking because
parking sucks looking for a space
driving round and round a structure
maneuvering in and out without just
kissing a concrete pillar here you just
drive straight into the robotic parking
garage lock your car and walk away let's
go and see it from the inside this
automated parking garage in West
Hollywood California uses horizontal and
vertical shuttles to gently move cars
into stacks of parking spaces what this
does it eliminates all the turning
radiuses all the ramps all the
clearances for people to be able to walk
here or to open up the doors and and
will actually notice the cars will
squash pretty close right oh yeah right
so in the same volume we can put between
two to three times the number of spaces
they're lifted and moved by these insect
like dollies that follow lines on the
floor they clamp their pincers gently
around the tires and push the car up
before autonomously marching themselves
back to the shuttle with the cars on
their backs like little workarounds the
system always analyzes and calculates
the fastest route to take your car so
it's very dynamic at the end of every
movement it's recalculating the fastest
route down it's really a building sized
game of Tetris spin the cars around and
move them to free up space and it's all
completely computer controlled usually
this place is totally sealed off nobody
comes inside there is a lot of
complexity compared to a regular
concrete parking structure but as well
as a smaller footprint the garage saves
on noise and emissions because none of
the cars have their engines running it
also worked out 1 million dollars
cheaper to build because a conventional
garage would have needed more materials
to make it bigger for the same number of
spaces
max throughput is around a hundred cars
an hour the weight can be around 10
minutes to get your car back which feels
like ages but really isn't when you
compare it to getting in an elevator and
going to fetch your own vehicle besides
driving yourself is like so 2015
electronics had already patented
a few patents that relate to the
integration of autonomous vehicle in our
autonomous parking systems and we are
working with the bigger leading
companies on building those interfaces
between the systems so that the cars can
come in park themselves pay and go and
pick you up
everything autonomously and if we ever
do stop using cars altogether they can
be designed so that the spaces can be
converted into apartments or offices
when it's time to leave the process from
the outside at least is simple
insert your ticket pay get into your car
and then just drive off